Costigan Bressman is berapa welcome to a
brand new game called dude stop also
what you say when your bro gets a little
too close so basically this box says
it's supposed to go up well we're just
gonna have to see about that
hahaha
Oh
oh it's that so much bookmark well
wouldn't it be a shame if someone pulled
it out only time pulling out is not cool
oh look a straight painting would be
ashamed if they got tilted look Oh a
toilet seat would be a shame if it was
up why can't women just put them up
instead of guys putting them down sexism
that was it
ah yay I found a secret awesome
we got level pike - Oh a stem well I
guess I'll just put just kidding
oh we got the red of bread skittles and
blue skittles really blue okay I'm
cutting out colorblind I swear to God
all right well I guess I'll just have to
put bra just right what if I just throw
it away
so you can complete all the oldest stuff
as a good guy
I want to try that all right I'm a good
guy let's face it it wasn't fun I'll put
the stamp in there ah ah
everyone's OCD is just getting cured yes
just go down just go down my man oh it
feels good right into Papa ah what is
this a gift oh yay for me for being a
totally normal person that's amazing
there's two more trophies okay so if I
say yes and then yes again do I get a
[ __ ] trophy really that's so dumb
what is this trophy what is this trophy
what is this true
the final trophy the most coveted of all
the Trump trophy to get the final trophy
you must think like Trump look like
drama become Trump oh my god okay
who should we vote for 2016
well we have this one and the one with
amazing hair Donald Trump
oh look at that a Trump true that Trump
trophy trophy trophy wow that was the
secret huh
see voting for Donald Trump isn't so bad
after all it's a check out this game see
if you can find any more trophies it's
really fun and I'll see you bros in next
video don't forget to leave a like it
helps out a lot and I'll see you in the
next video thank you so much there are
some brush [ __ ] I professed it to you
too hard I'm sorry hey I need help with
my ABS your ass I don't see why you
can't do this yourself that is spring
Nicolas to your genitals sir